Zoomers are shacking up
they are not getting married but they
are moving in together according to the
Census Bureau more than 11 percent of
Americans aged 18 to 24 lived with a
romantic partner who is not a spouse
last year that is the highest share of
Young Americans doing that sort of thing
ever and there are all sorts of reasons
as to why they're doing it to save money
convenience pleasure but I suspect the
main reason that they are shacking up at
a higher rate than ever before is that
Society tells them there's nothing wrong
with it there's no reason not to
which has me thinking about how things
used to be I'm not thinking about the
1950s
I'm not even thinking about the 1850s
I am thinking a little further back
all the way to the 1050s
all the way back to a now little-known
Group by the name of the albigensians
if you've never heard of the
albigensians it was this strange
religious group that had a lot of
bizarre ideas
they believed that the world was not
created by an all-loving God and that
sin and death pervaded the world because
of a man's abuse of his Free Will and
Adam and even all the rest of it they
believe that two principles two mutually
opposing principles created the world
the good principle and the bad principle
the good principle is the principle of
spirit the bad principle was the
principle of the material world and so
the albigensians believed that spiritual
things were good and pure and true they
believed that their true selves their
true identity was purely spiritual
purely metaphysical and they believed
that all the stuff of the physical world
including their bodies was evil and
terrible
and so you might say well they just had
some quirky ideas who cares Live and Let
Live the problem with the albigensians
was that their movement was spreading
and their movement
threatened civilization it was
destroying Society everywhere it went
because ideas have consequences so the
albigensians
hating all the material world thinking
everything was evil they discouraged
marriage they redefined marriage and
outlawed it they discouraged people from
getting married they encouraged
concubines they actually encouraged
jacking up if that was the alternative
to be married because it was more
temporary they hated procreation they
strongly discouraged procreation they
encouraged vegetarianism and fasts even
to the point of starvation they
encouraged suicide and they hoped for
the eradication of the human race the
whole human race they thought these
humans growing and populating that was
really really bad this physical world is
so bad we've got to get rid of it
certain Echoes of this very bad idea
seem to reverberate through modern times
but fortunately the forces of
civilization were able to overcome
the albigensians and civilization lived
to see another day bad ideas left
uncorrected bad ideas embraced and
enshrined in culture and law
and custom have the power to destroy
civilizations if the forces of
civilization don't root them out first
just been thinking about that lately I
don't know I don't know why we have got
a lot of these bad ideas going around
the culture we'll get to there's a video
we'll get to a little bit later of
lieutenant governor in Minnesota
Democrat of course
pushing not only insane ideologies onto
children
but pushing an insane ideology about
children which we will get to but first
we've got to fill up our brains with
knowledge of what's in the news and you
might need to fill up your propane tank
at home before you go grilling which is
why you got to check out cinch right now
go to cinch.com use promo code nulls it
is starting to get a little bit warmer
down here in Tennessee finally friends
and neighbors are already breaking out
their barbecues now the last thing that
you're going to want to do when you're
getting ready to take that Grill pill
have a weekend cookout is to drive
around trying to find a place to refill
your propane tank that is why you need
cinch cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door cinch delivers
on your schedule no long-term commitment
no subscription none of that plus
delivery is completely contactless you
don't have to be home to receive the
delivery you don't really have to do
much of anything at all you can track
the order on the Cinch app from anywhere
whether you are grilling for the game
camping or enjoying a cozy fire on a
cold night maybe a nice romantic little
evening cinch's propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel that you
need to make the most of every moment go
online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just 10 bucks
with promo code Knolls you can also go
to cinch.com or download the Cinch app
and use promo code nulls kwles to get
your first tank exchange for just ten
dollars
c-ynch.com promo code knows it's a
limited time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it
cinch.com offer for details
ideas have consequences this is why
societies need to encourage good ideas
and discourage bad ideas
this is why societies have standards and
Norms because ideas are not just things
that float around in the air they're not
just things that float around in our
heads but they impel people to action
and they transform society and in some
cases they can destroy Society give you
an example of ideas having consequences
there's an idea out there that
conservatives have no right to speak in
public
this is an idea pretty much only on the
left the right Wingers never seem to
mind
or very rarely at least seem to mind
when the left Wingers hold public events
and rallies and speeches
the left Wingers always hate it they're
trying to cancel multiple speeches and
speaking events of mine right now as
they've been doing for years at this
point Charlie Kirk was just giving a
speech at a university in California
and this was some of the most intense
pushback to a speech I have ever seen
there were barricades put up in the room
where Charlie Kirk was speaking
there were protesters who were beating
down the door I think a police officer
was injured people were arrested these
were violent leftist agitators at UC
Davis and some of them actually made
their way into the building before they
were removed
now the consensus view for many years
has been that when leftists make fools
of themselves at these events when they
scream and they shriek and they get
violent and that that's really bad for
them
because it's exposing how unreasonable
they are and it makes the conservatives
look really really good because we're
the reasonable ones
we're the normal ones how could anybody
support the left
the problem with this consensus view
though
is that the libs keep winning
the libs keep winning on all the things
that they want the libs keep radically
redefining fundamental aspects of our
society the libs keep winning lots and
lots of Elections even when the libs
don't win elections the libs keep
ramming their policies through through
the courts and through the bureaucracy
the libs have succeeded in their
revolutionary plan all the way down to
now redefining what it means to be a man
and what it means to be a woman so how
do you make sense of that
if
these violent outbursts are so bad for
the lips why do the lips keep winning
and why do the lips keep doing them
because it's not bad for the lips yes
the lips look crazy and foolish and
unreasonable when for instance they burn
the country down through BLM for eight
months yes they look crazy and wild and
unreasonable when they totally
misrepresent scientific studies and lock
every American in their homes and make
us all wear hankies on our face and
force us to take an experimental drug
even young children who are
statistically virtually no risk from a
virus and yes they look ridiculous when
they make a stand six feet away and yes
they look ridiculous when they don't
enforce the law and yes they look
ridiculous when they attack
conservatives in public
but then why do they keep winning
because
ideas have consequences and one of the
consequences of of their ideas
is that they will intimidate
conservatives in public they will
intimidate the public and so
corporations will bend the knee
even parents frequently will bend the
knee the citizenry will bend the knee
because they just don't want to deal
with it because those threats actually
threaten them and they they don't want
to have to deal
with the consequences of it that's a
scary thing and that's why you've got to
put down certain ideas
the the left at this point would would
seem to deny objective truth
often seems to certainly denies the
traditional moral order it seems to have
their own cockamami ideas instead
and and those we can't we can't divorce
their actions from their ideas if you're
only trying to address the actions okay
we're going to force this conservative
speaking event through okay we're going
to arrest some of the violent rioters
you're not dealing with the problem
if you want to
preserve Society you've got to go after
the bad ideas some might say you have to
eradicate those bad ideas now Liberals
are losing on one front
that would be the Oscars meant to get to
this yesterday the ratings are out for
the Oscars and the libs are bragging
they're saying the Oscars ratings
are back up they're up to 16 million
viewers see Hollywood's back Hollywood
which is one of the biggest microphones
for the liberal establishment out there
Hollywood's back baby people are tuning
in but
while it is true that 16 million is an
improvement over 2021 let's say when the
covid lockdowns shut down the film
industry there were basically no new
films
it's up from 10.4 million in 2021.
just the year before that the Oscar's
ratings were 23.6 million
so now they're down by seven and a half
million
it's a huge number
but before 2020 2019 it was 29 and a
half million
hovered around there for a while 2017
was 30 32.9 million
couple years before that 37.3 million
year before that 2014
43.7 million now we're down to 16 and
they're saying this is a big victory all
right we went from almost 44 million
viewers to 16 million viewers in a span
of about nine years but hey we're up a
little bit from last year it's a big win
we're back so that doesn't convince
anybody obviously Hollywood's influence
has declined considerably
it's not just because of technological
progress because people are tuning out
because Hollywood is making movies that
are absurd and don't tell true stories
and insult the audience
but that's not my main takeaway yeah
sure the movies are dead Hollywood's
losing influence okay great
my main takeaway here
is that this trend of celebrating a
slight uptick after a total collapse
is how our society is working today I've
frequently criticized the conservatives
for this
we counted a victory when the Liberals
take 90 percent of the field and we walk
them back two percent
we counted a victory hey guys big win
big win guys the Liberals are gonna have
to wait until our children turn six to
trans them yeah that's right baby yeah
we lost our customs and our way of life
and the way men and women interact and
the definition of marriage and and even
the definition of man and woman but but
hey it's a really big win because the
Liberals are gonna wait until hold on oh
there's an update the Liberals are gonna
wait till our kids are three to trans
them yeah big win because they wanted to
transmit Age Two congratulations
everybody no that's not a big one that's
a that's a huge loss
an uptick from 11 million viewers to 16
million viewers
is a huge loss when nine years ago it
was 40 43 million viewers 44 million
viewers
that's our whole culture
we say hey guys
inflation was only eight percent this
month big win that's big stuff huh guys
hey we only had 2.3 million illegal
border crossers last year yeah that's
right what a big win what a great
Improvement
no we're just we're just normalizing
Decay and decline I don't want to
normalize that
I want to normalize that at all
in order to address a problem
you have to look at that problem Square
in the face
in the American liberal establishment
obviously doesn't want to do that it
paints a very Rosy picture
but even the conservatives
the conservatives their favorite drug is
copium you know they just really want to
take out a big pipe and smoke a big bowl
of copium
because looking the problem in the face
is so jarring
think about everything we have lost in a
matter of just a few decades
we conservatives could not conserve the
women's bathroom
we say hey but we're we're on the verge
of a comeback maybe we are maybe we
aren't I don't see a ton of evidence of
that that we're on the verge of a
comeback
unless we start to to take on a bolder
vision
the Liberals have a bold vision
and they express that bold Vision
through political violence which I think
is unjust and immoral
I don't think the ends ever justify the
mean so I'm not suggesting that but I am
suggesting that we use just political
means to affect a much more ambitious
political agenda it will work we don't
need to be afraid of ambition we don't
need to be afraid of a grand coherent
vision
okay the libs have that the the the
Green New Deal is insane but it's a
clear vision and is it radical yes and
are people coming around to it yes
abolish the police is an insane crazy
radical idea but it's a clear idea and
many people have come around to it it
has it has been normalized in our
society
conservatives need to do that as well
we need to stop thinking that decline is
inevitable we need to stop thinking that
the libs are always going to win and we
just are going to slow them down a
little bit
we need to give people a choice I was on
the whatever podcast and a couple of the
girls on the podcast made an interesting
observation that has actually affected
my political thinking which is they
disagreed with me I was very
conservative they were very liberal so
they they would disagree with me for a
lot of the show the host of that show
Brian is somewhat liberal he's certainly
not as conservative as I am it would
seem
and
the girls were really upset with him
they said your your opinion Brian is
contradictory they said at least Michael
at least he's clear at least he knows
what he wants
I don't mean to
you know Grant any criticism of Brian
you know he has a great show and every
but that was their observation
that Brian we might agree with you more
in your relative centrism
but we're more persuaded by Michael's
argument because he even though he's
more conservative than us he has a Clear
Vision he knows what he wants
voters are like that too you've got to
know what you want voters will vote for
a vision and they will follow the lead
of leaders
that's how the libs have won for decades
that's how we could win again too so
the country at the moment is in pretty
clear decline on pretty much every front
this would explain why the country is
turning inward on the foreign policy
front
why at least the opposition in this
country which is the conservatives why
why we're turning inward
and it's not just the isolationist
Fringe of the right wing
it's even one of the leading Republican
presidential candidates for 2024 that
would be Ron DeSantis who has turned his
vision inward when it comes to the war
in Ukraine uh he just told Tucker
Carlson quote
well the U.S has many vital national
interests becoming further entangled in
a territorial dispute between Ukraine
and Russia is not one of them so the
squishes and the libs and the neocons
and the uh whatever term you want to use
for the more Centrist liberal
establishment wing of the party they are
furious at Ron DeSantis for saying you
know I don't think we need to write a
blank check to Ukraine and
some of the more conservative Maga
right-wing people in the Republican
party they don't believe him because not
that long ago Ron DeSantis was
advocating for more intervention in
Ukraine you're better off dealing with
Putin by being strong I mean we've tried
to deal with some of this in the
Congress a couple years ago we
authorized lethal aid for Ukraine so
that they could resist some of the
Russian incursion uh the Obama
Administration fought us on that uh but
I think that's the type of thing when
when Putin sees he can gain an inch he's
acted apt to take a mile and basically
if America is not going to give him any
pushback I think he's going to continue
to try to expand Russian influence okay
so from the pro-trump camp this is one
of the clips that says that that they
insist proves that DeSantis isn't for
real he's blown in the wind and we can't
really trust him to execute the America
First agenda but but this is Complicated
by the fact that President Trump
previously had also argued for greater
involvement in Ukraine
remember that with Ukraine I sent the
javelins that you see are so effective
against the tanks Biden didn't and in
fact he ended our last order probably
it'll get there because everyone
realized it was the right thing to do
and Obama remember Obama Biden they sent
blankets I send javelins and they said
well you know what the Japanese are the
anti-tank weapon say knock the hell out
of those tanks
and Ukraine wouldn't be having a chance
without him that was all sent by me all
of it we sent other military equipment
to we didn't send our soldiers but we
sent them a lot of equipment
okay and he makes a distinction there he
says we're not sending soldiers but we
sent him a lot of equipment we've we've
been funding the Ukraine war effort so
what does this mean it means that Trump
and DeSantis are running in the same
Lane
and they've
both taken all sorts of contradictory
positions over the years
now president Trump is very anti-free
trade he's very pro-tariff there were
op-ed there was one op-ed in particular
that I'm thinking of that was published
in his name when he was considering
running for president first time and it
was a very pro-free trade Pro
globalization sort of op-ed obviously he
became much more protectionist and and
now advocates for a type of mercantilism
there are also videos of of Ron DeSantis
saying I'm very pro-free trade he took
votes that were pro-free trade now it
would appear he's making a little turn
so what does this mean it means that
both these guys are running in the same
Lane
there for the rest of the campaign they
will both be trying to run in the same
Lane
Trump is going to say I'm Trump I'm one
of a kind I'm an American original I'm
the guy who changed the Republican party
I've done it before I'll do it again Ron
DeSantis is going to say president Trump
had his time he didn't win re-election
he's undisciplined and so I'm Trump
without the baggage but I'm I'm going to
be a type of trump I'm just going to be
the the new and improved version of
trump they're both running in the same
Lane so the question for primary voters
I don't think is going to be parsing
different issues I doubt that there's
going to be much daylight at all on any
of these issues I suspect the question
is going to come down to who do you
trust more to do it so right now Ronda
Santos after some bad news in recent
weeks in the polls with President Trump
taking his lead back DeSantis not really
growing in the polls according to a CNN
SSRS poll
DeSantis is now at top of the Republican
primary field 39 to Trump's 37 so
essentially tied Haley's at seven Pence
is at six Tim Scott's at two so noon
news at 2 Junkin is even in the poll
he's at one percent
uh so it remains anybody's race the
national polls don't really matter when
it comes to presidential primaries
because because the primaries happen
state by state so what matters is who's
a lady in Iowa who's leading in New
Hampshire who's leading in South
Carolina who's leading in Florida
because as momentum builds that's how
you're going to see the the the real
hierarchy of candidates begin to shape
up it won't happen for a while but
according to another poll more than
one-third of Biden voters do not want
him to run again and so you can expect
more Republican candidates and all sorts
of different Lanes you're going to have
the Centrist Lane you're going to have
the neocon lane you're going to have the
libertarian Lane and you're gonna have
the Trump Lane and right now you've got
two candidates running in that lane
so we just we got to make sure that we
clear the air and when you want to clear
the air you've got to check out
rabbit air right now go to rabbitair.com
tell them Michael Knowles sent you so
guess where I was last night I'll tell
you I was maybe out a little late on a
school night I was not at home I was at
a cigar bar that I really enjoy I was
there with a couple of buddies and guess
what the cigar bar which smells great
really really high-end Cigar Bar guess
what they use to clean the air they use
the same air purifier that I use that
you should use rabbit air rabbit Air's
award-winning air purifiers are some of
the absolute best in the industry
they've got Advanced six stage
filtration and deodorization that can
reduce Airborne particles odors and
pollutants to keep your air clean and
fresh they're highly customizable you
can do everything from your phone the
thing basically runs itself if you want
it to it's got an odor remover for
stogies it's got a pet allergy filter
it's just got everything that you need
visit rabbitair.com to speak to a rabbit
air consultant that is
r-a-b-b-i-t-a-i-r Dot com do not forget
to check out their artists series and
special editions for a more
aesthetically pleasing product design
make sure to tell them that Michael
Knowles sent you my favorite comment
yesterday is from Isaac Glover
who says you mean to tell me it's easier
to get into a five-star Gordon Ramsay
restaurant than to be dealt with by
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
in New York City yes
because
even a five-star restaurant a Michelin
rated restaurant
probably doesn't have a nine-year wait
list
probably you might have to wait a year
you might have to wait a year and a half
you probably won't have to wait nine
years
so I I hope that the illegal aliens who
have violated one of the most basic laws
of our country and who have been
arrested or are known to be in the
country and then let go and told to hang
out for a better part of a decade I hope
they enjoy many Michelin rated meals
before they maybe get an appointment
with the people who are supposed to be
enforcing our immigration laws
moving on a little bit to the culture
here there is a clip going around of the
Minnesota lieutenant governor Peggy
Flanagan and Peggy Flanagan is
articulating a view of the the issue
that everybody's talking about
constantly which is transgenderism but
she's not even just articulating a view
of how to deal with the transgender
issue
she's articulating a view of the way
that parents should relate to children
broadly let's be clear
this is life of affirming and
life-saving health care
when our children tell us who they are
it is our job as grown-ups to listen and
to believe them
come on
the libs invert everything
they don't just
pervert things they invert everything
the libs call good evil and evil good
they call truth falsehood and falsehood
truth
they call Beauty ugly and ugliness
Beauty
we see this on the Billboards we see
this in our classrooms we see this in
public speeches and the way they talk
about morality and virtue and here
they have inverted
the way that we talk about raising
children
they've obviously inverted men and women
now men or women and women are men
but now
children or parents and parents are
children
she says it is our job when our when our
children tell us something it is our job
to believe them
that that is not true
I
I love my children
more than my own life I love my children
I listen to every little Babble and
every little word that they utter
but I don't just believe everything they
tell me
because my children are one is a toddler
and one is a little baby who can't even
speak yet and they don't they don't know
lots of things
they say things that don't make a lot of
sense
a lot of the time it is my job to teach
them
and it is their job to believe me as
they are learning that's why it's
important to be a good parent so you can
raise your kid up right and then if you
raise your kid right then he will he
will have developed his own rational
faculties
and his own solid formation of you of
the world and so then he can examine
some of those ideas he might even
disagree with you on some things
and then he'll be a fully functioning
adult and
and the generations go on
if a child comes to you
and says
daddy mommy I'm really really fat
and the child is really really thin
it is not your job to believe that child
you say oh I guess you're right darling
okay no more cupcakes
if that very thin child comes to her
parents and says mommy daddy I'm really
really fat
it's the parents duty to say no you're
really thin you're actually dangerously
thin there's a problem with your
perception of yourself
and you are going to eat and you're
maybe going to go see a psychologist and
you're we're going to help you
that's the job of a parent if a if a
child
suffering from a less common mental
illness let's say
a child comes to his parents and says
mommy daddy
I hear voices
in my room at night
it's a really little child you might say
oh you're imagining things it's an
imaginary friend but if that let's say
that child's 12 years old 14 years old
said Mommy Daddy when you turn the light
out at night I hear voices in my room
your job is not to believe them and say
oh well let's find out where those
monsters are hiding
your job is not to affirm them in in
that delusion and say hey you're right
Johnny oh what are what are their names
oh moloch and ball and Legion oh wow
well I I can't wait to meet him sometime
no your job is to say no no that's not
true there's a problem with your
perception something's misfiring
and I know you're convinced of your
delusion but no you should listen to me
here and we should get you help to fix
your perception the job of parents I'm
not saying that parents need to be harsh
or tyrannical or anything like that
parents of course should listen to their
children the job of the parents is to
encourage children means to give heart
okay and sometimes that involves tough
love I think of the bio tapestry the
famous tapestry of the Battle of
Hastings 1066. and in it there's a very
famous
picture of a guy who looks like a bishop
got a little Bishop hatties holding a
club
and he's hitting these soldiers but
they're his own soldiers
and the caption says here Bishop Odo
strengthens the boys
encourages the boys
it's encouraging because he's beating
them with a club because uh he was a
bishop and he was not allowed to carry a
sword and kill people during the battle
but he was able to
beat over the head his own retreating
forces and send them back into the
battle sometimes love has to be a little
bit tough but if it's from a position of
Charity and if it's done to encourage if
it's done uh to to help somebody and to
really strengthen them and to to take
away cowardice and falsehood and fear
and anxiety and lies that is a very good
thing the job of parents is to encourage
their children not to scandalize them
Scandal is when you provide an
impediment a stumbling block to somebody
so when a confused child says I don't
know let me just let me think of a
hypothetical example if a little boy
says hey Mommy and Daddy I'm really a
little girl
and then the parents say maybe you are
oh Ari yeah maybe you are you did you
picked up a Barbie one time maybe I
guess you are a girl
that is Scandal that's scandalous that's
that's creating a stumbling block for
that child's development
and
the gospels are quite clear on this
Christ says woe to those who scandalize
the little ones the least of these be
better for a millstone to be tight
around their neck
to around the people who scandalize
those little children and often this
this line is is uh invoked by people as
if to refer to abortion as if to refer
to physically harming a child but it's
not it's actually talking about causing
a child to stumble
to scandalize them which is what our
whole society is doing right now
speaking of
all these crazy identity politics
there's a viral tick tocker
who has a message
to white people you know very often
these
these ideas critical race Theory and all
of the modern woke ideologies they they
present themselves as so complicated oh
there's just so it's problematic and
complicated and you need to have read
all of these really esoteric thinkers to
understand the meaning of well not this
lady this lady has a very clear message
on race
I'm feeling spicy so here's my hot take
of the day all white people are racist
every single last one of them all of
them are racist and I don't mean that to
say like every single individual white
person if I talk to you you would have
some kind of racist ideology I'm saying
that as a white person you uphold a
system of racism by literally just being
white I believe if you're not spending
your literal entire life dismantling
racism then you're contributing to its
continuation and people get so much
literal entire life
not figurative entire life literal
entire life
so if you don't spend every
single moment of your whole life
if you ever sleep
if you ever blink
and are not in that moment fighting
racism you're a terrible racist by
virtue of being a white person which
which brings you back to the first point
you made which is all white people
all the time are evil terrible racists
let's keep going
like yes yes you're racist like okay
okay establish that now what are you
gonna do to change it racism refers to
power
nothing I guess
nothing I guess if that's if that's the
premise
that all white people all the time by
virtue of being white are racist
then okay
I thought maybe there was something I
could do to change it I thought maybe
there was some way that I could improve
or practice virtue or do good things but
I can't even though she's saying again
what are you going to do to change it
she tells you for the first part of the
video there's nothing you can do to
change it you are a white person you are
evil you are useless you are hopeless
everything you do by virtue of who you
are is evil so I guess the only the only
possible answer to that
if you accept that premise is
okay
guess I'm a racist then whatever
whatever okay then I'll stop caring all
right I just won't worry about it
anymore
it was a great meme of the way that uh
conservative thought has evolved in just
the last 10 years
the first the first part of it is the
Tea Party guy he says hey let me tell
you about your constitutional rights
we're all countrymen let's just get back
to basics and the founding fathers and
cut taxes and okay then the second one
that's more the Maga movement they say
hey there's some real problems here I
mean we're all still Americans we all
still love each other and you know but
you guys got to stop being so tough on
us and we're gonna have some rights and
maybe we shouldn't totally have open
borders and and then the last panel is
just this guy he's got five o'clock
shadow he's just
seen a lot you know smoking a cigarette
he says oh okay I'm evil I guess I'm
racist and phobic and cool whatever and
oh yeah you're gonna oh you're gonna
you're gonna call me all sorts of mean
names whatever bro LOL fine and it just
doesn't affect him anymore
that's the only rational response to
this video I remember when I was in
college Ann Coulter came to visit and
she said that when a liberal calls you a
racist you know you've won the argument
that's how I feel I mean they'll do it
to anybody often they'll do it to black
people if they don't know that those
conservatives are black I always go back
to this example of David Webb who's a
black conservative radio host and some
liberal caller didn't know what he
looked like and just the minute he
started to win the argument she just
accused him of white privilege and he
just laughed I'd say okay that's fine
we're all racist okay yeah cool fine
whatever who are the powerful race in a
society then your faces like I just
don't understand why it's so taboo let's
talk about it so that we can work
together we're never gonna get anywhere
and people won't just acknowledge in the
first place yeah I guess we're not
getting anywhere I guess you're right
you're saying we can't get anywhere so
okay
so it's obviously not Ted but it's not
taboo to say white people are racist or
evil or terrible in fact it's encouraged
by the society
white people and to some degree Asians
it's the only race that you can legally
discriminate against and that you're
encouraged to insult so
okay
yeah that's not taboo you're right
let's just talk yeah okay sure you said
it you're right yeah we're all the worst
people in the world uh-huh okay there's
nothing we can do to change yet all
right
whatever
next I don't know swipe up okay what's
the next Tick Tock a little literally
here what is the next Tick Tock is from
from Sam Harris the liberal atheist
attacking uh the one of the black faces
of white supremacy our friend Candace
Owens we're swimming in a sea of
misinformation where you've got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who sh who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no butterflies
there
Sam Harris
Sam Harris best known
for
for trying to convince edgy 13 year olds
not to believe in God same that's what
he's known for he's known as one of the
four new atheists which was this kind of
contrived publishing movement in the
mid-2000s Sam Harris who I don't mean to
insult him or anything like that but not
you know not not the highest finest
intellectual in the world okay he's just
a he was a sort of a publishing thing
and he had this really silly idea and
it's one of the and it's probably the
single dumbest idea anybody can have in
the world which is that God does not
exist and he has the audacity to tell
people that they should not have an
opinion
Sam Harris the great liberal the great
liberal we hear it all out we're
pro-free speech so certain people
shouldn't have an opinion who are those
people
there is no scenario in which you should
be getting your opinion about vaccine
safety or or climate change or
uh the war in Ukraine or anything else
that we might want to talk about from
Candace Owens right it's just like it
like like she she's not a relevant
expert on any of those topics and what's
more she doesn't seem to care
he said a few true things there
he said two true things the Candace
Owens is not a relative expert
or not a relevant expert that's true she
doesn't have a white lab coach she
doesn't have a medical degree she didn't
study epidemiology at Johns Hopkins
that's true
and it's also true that she doesn't care
she's going to give her opinion whether
Sam Harris wants her to or not
there's something here that Sam Harris
missed
which is that when it comes to vaccine
safety
it comes to the efficacy of the covid
vaccine
Candice Owens was right
and all of the relevant experts were
wrong
it's this really weird fact
that on the pressing public matters
regular people
are often right
and the relevant experts with all the
special credentials who Sam Harris gives
a stamp of approval to
are frequently if not always wrong
so if we're going to take away the
ability of either of these groups to
have an opinion that is public
wouldn't it make more sense to take away
Dr fauci's platform wouldn't it make
more sense to take away the platform of
the CDC or the who which totally botched
covet
wouldn't it make sense to take away the
platform of Sam Harris who's wrong about
pretty much everything
is if I'm just judging by who's right
and who's wrong
that's right you know I'm giving I have
this debate it's still scheduled we'll
see if the administration cancels it I
have a debate on transgenderism with
with a transgender scholar a supposedly
distinguished Professor with three
degrees from Harvard and a half a dozen
honorary doctorates and dozens of
academic Publications who is a man who
identifies as a woman and he calls
himself Deirdre and his real name is
Donald and he's supposedly this
distinguished scholar he's got all of
these degrees and credentials and he's
been tweeting about our debate and the
only points that he's really made about
the debate he wants the debate to go on
and he said Knowles is a fascist Knowles
is a fascist he's he used the phrase he
said I'm an anti-jesus Catholic
what is it so I guess cat he's a
fiscopalian that's where they talk about
you know glass houses but he's accusing
the Catholics I guess of being
anti-jesus I don't know that's he's the
expert he's the he's the distinguished
scholar so you're a fascist you're mean
you're an evil I hate you
I I haven't said anything like that at
all I've only said relatively
complimentary things about him
I don't I'm not I'm not some
distinguished scholar I don't have any
particularly Advanced degree
that's the way it goes and I happen to
be right on the question men or men and
women are women and you know who else is
right every normal person who has ever
lived for all of human history
are all right
it takes multiple degrees from Harvard
not to know what a woman is
ask Justice katanji Jackson
despite the lackluster economy or maybe
because of it the daily wire is thriving
and not only that we are hiring we are
currently looking for a video editor to
join our fast growing production team
this person will get the opportunity to
work on a variety of content including
our daily podcasts long form interviews
YouTube videos as well as shows such as
Ben Shapiro's debunked documentaries
from Jordan Peterson and more four plus
years of professional video editing
experience and familiarity in working in
a very fast-paced environment with high
turnaround times is required bonus
points for experience working on viral
YouTube content this is the perfect role
for someone who can expertly follow
standardized video editing formats while
also possessing a strong creative skill
set a link to your reel is required for
consideration the position is based in
Nashville Tennessee for more information
and to apply visit dailywire.com
careersdailywire.com careers today
I
talked about the scientists I talked
about Trump I talked about Biden we've
we've got to get to one other candidate
for president who has just announced his
run
he's not getting nearly enough coverage
even though the announcement came
yesterday classic lame stream media
doesn't want to cover the real
candidates that person of course would
be
Joe exotic
yes the Tiger King who is currently in
prison
for hiring a Hitman to kill his Nemesis
Carol Baskin
Joe exotic
is declared that he is running as a
Republican
for president
in his announcement he said put aside
that I am gay that I am in prison for
now that I used drugs in the past that I
had more than one boyfriend at once and
that Carol hates my guts
this all has not a thing to do with me
being able to be your voice
the best thing you have going for
supporting me is that I am used to
fighting my whole life just to get by I
am broke they have taken everything I
ever worked for away and it's time we
take this country back
now
Joe has a couple of points elsewhere in
his announcement he said I'm just in
prison because of the corruption of the
justice department and I don't think
that's true I think he's imprisoned
because he hired a hit man to kill a
lady
but his point is that justice department
is corrupt
even at uh Whitaker the former acting uh
attorney general who said that there is
a two-tiered system of justice in the
United States
we know that the justice department goes
hard after pro-life grannies and goes
hard after horn-headed people being
given a private tour by police around
the capitol on January 6 taking selfies
but they allowed BLM off the hook we
know that that's true
we know that people can change America
is the place of Second Chances and we
know that candidates who have nothing to
lose or sometimes the very best
candidates
this is one of the arguments for Trump
actually is they've thrown everything at
him they've taken away everything of his
that they can
short of throwing them in prison and so
he's not he's not really beholden to
anybody that's true
that said it would appear that Joe
Exotic is basically unrepentant uh I I'm
not sure that he's really reformed any
of his ways at all and so I will not
I will I don't I don't want to endorse
in the primaries but I don't think that
I will be supporting Joe Exotic for his
run though he can run and presidential
candidates have run before from prison
Eugene Debs famously a socialist ran
from prison and he got something like
eight percent of the vote so don't if
you're in it you can win it don't write
any candidate out including Joe Exotic
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it
uh you can become a member right now at
dailywire.com using promo code Knowles
at checkout you will get two months free
on all annual plans Mr Davies has lots
of secret special fun things planned for
the
inner circle of the members block we'll
see you over there thank you
[Music]